i've been called
all kinds of things casper
snow white
ugly
just all kinds of mean terrible things
peoples have said that i wouldn't make
it as a model but i am a model
i'm deandra farris
i was one of the first models with
albinism science to a major modeling
agency
albinism is a gene that causes lack of
pigment and hair skin and eyes
i grew up in the bronx so there is a lot
of either
blacks or hispanics
people were always like what are you you
know
i was like yeah i'm black or
african-american and it's like no you're
not
i'm just like okay how are you going to
tell me what i am
rain is my daughter
my
eight week now old daughter
we're a very
blended family
when it comes to skin color
black comes in all shades so
we're just adding more complexions to my
families
i walked the runway with rain during
fashion week and she slept the whole
time
i want her to grow up to be you know her
own person not afraid to ask questions
know who she is and be interested to
know who other people are as well
i didn't always feel beautiful
words do hurt you know i am bothered by
things people say
but
you know there's beauty in everybody and
i think it should be celebrated
once you feel the confidence and know
who you are as a person
it can't really affect you anymore
you